sommes avec paul thompson vice-président
du parti conservateur britannique en
france bonsoir paul thompson merci
d'être avec nous france ce soir
invitation alors l'accord du break site
semble être en bonne voie pour être
conclu les parlementaires britanniques
auront rendez vous le 30 décembre
l'opposition a déjà annoncé qu'elle
voterait pour il ya donc aucune
inquiétude et ou énième retournement de
situation à avoir ah non pas vraiment il
y aura peut-être quelques grincheux à
qui trouveront à critiquer est arrivé 2
octobre
normal qu'il y ait des débats mais ils
seront très court et je pense qu'il est
exclu que ce ce qu'il ya le moindre
risque de déraillement alors qui ressort
vainqueur de cet accord qui a fait le
plus de coupes promis l'union européenne
ou le royaume uni
je pense à que vous allez me poser de
questions et ma réponse très très
sincèrement et que les deux sont son
vainqueur
parce que ce que plusieurs des personnes
que vous avez laissé s'exprimer ou
maxime en raison de dire que c'était
très important pour les deux côtés de
parvenir à un accord
d'abord parce que chaque chaque partie
un vrai intérêt à le faire mais si
généralement d'été très important de
créer de bonnes bases saines stable et
consensuelle pour l'avenir et ça c'est
vraiment un point essentiel qu'il n'y
avait pas eu d'accord on en rêve ne peut
le contraire de tout ça c'est à dire de
l'acrimonie
des critiques et un sorte de de jeu de
deux blâmes un peu de tous les côtés
pendant très longtemps potentiellement
tonkam donc être à ce moment je pense
que les deux côtés sont souvent corps en
un maintien
emmanuel ma croix à féliciter cet accord
il a notamment souligné le soutien
apporté aux pêcheurs cela signifie que
c'est un bon deal qu'est ce que ça
implique pour les futures relations
france royaume-uni en le mollah la même
chose et que là nous relations
bilatérales en spécialité très important
on ne le dit pas assez je trouve la
coopération en matière de renseignement
sur le terrorisme par exemple en
politique étrangère en matière de
défense est unique et a appelé à se
développer mais c'est déjà très très
profond et très négative et emmanuel
macron je crois bien a dit à plusieurs
reprises que cette relation devait se
maintenir et se fortifier je crois que
c'est ce qu'il croit réellement et côté
britannique on est sur la même longueur
d'onde donc donc sur nos relations
bilatérales
cette politique aussi en ce qui concerne
la tâche la france était en première
ligne très en pointe sur ce sujet c'est
vrai que là les plaines aussi de la
pêche en france elle tomber les plus
importantes en europe et la plupart de
leurs prix se font dans les eaux
territoriales britanniques ont cité un
vrai sujet là il y à un compromis qui me
paraît très bons ils eurent tour carrée
de cinq ans et demi avec 25% de la part
de l'union européen à 27 restitués ou au
royaume uni a donc 7 25% c'est l'impasse
en passant ce n'est pas 50 ans et 25%
des voix médiane donnait 60 je crois au
d'état
mais c'est pour une durée de cinq ans et
demi après après quoi il ya des
négociations entre l as été empreinte
relais pour le britannique donc là aussi
chaque chaque article vraiment et à
juste titre se dire qu il
il emporte des éléments essentiels de ce
qu'ils voulaient donc ça c'est le signe
de bon accord alors cet accord pose
m'excite c'est aussi une victoire pour
boris johnson qui jouait gros
finalement et là c'est un dénouement au
tennis attendait finalement oui
effectivement je trouve qu'en france il
est un patou le tout le respect ou non
ne l'apprécient pas à sa juste valeur je
trouve dans les médias parce que comment
c'est quelqu'un qui il à l'extérieur
jovial de très sérieuses et ils trésor
vient d'ailleurs à lille est d'une
grande culture open il est allé à la
même école jeunes que receveur fans de
rihanna ils se comprennent parfaitement
mais il considère le loing blick en
faisons car des intégrales de l'aura de
la culture de l'histoire et tout ça mais
il s'est battu contre beaucoup
d'obstacles et y compris au sein de sa
propre parti pour se faire respecter
le l'issue du référendum ce qui était en
jeu d'abord démocratique primordial et
lui croyait en plus dans le bien fondé
de l'idée générale de bauxite à cinq ans
qu'il était souhaitable que le royaume
uni recouvre une part plus importante
son autonomie mais pas de tous par par
hostilités vers l'union européenne où
vous allez la france a absolument pas et
donc il a dû se battre énormément
pendant toutes ces années et il a il
peut être vraiment fier de lui d'avoir
maintenant obtenu un résultat qui
permettent de base pour aller de l'avant
a entre l'om et l'europe et qui malgré
tout à procureront un mini il pas
d'autonomie
significativement plus élevés
qu'auparavant qu'à l'intérieur de ligue
1 parce qu'en matière de commerce
international aurait mené pour conclure
ses propres accords et dans le domaine
législatives il ya quand même beaucoup
plus de d'autonomie même s'il ya une
relation de coopération qui doit se
nouer sur de nouvelles bases et se
poursuivre donc qu'à qui produit une
seule
le mot de la fin merci beaucoup paul
thompson d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes vice-président
du parti conservateur britannique en
france